bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous est chef des urgences de
l'hôpital pompidou à paris vous êtes le
maire l air de la garenne collomb c'est
dans les hauts-de-seine
un mot d'abord sur cette actualité
l'actualité dramatique 1 2 hier soir de
cette nuit c'est ce policier qui est
mort hier à avignon il est mort dont
j'ai une opération anti drogue
est-ce que l'autorité de l'état est
aujourd'hui mise à mal dans notre pays
d'abord les forces de sécurité perd 1
perdre encore un homme elle paye un très
lourd tribut à cette situation
absolument incroyable de diminution à
deux démissions d'écroulement de
l'autorité en fait il ya un sentiment
d'impunité da par des délinquants
on le voit ça sera un des sujets majeurs
je pense dans les mois qui viennent dans
leur vie quotidienne les français n'en
peuvent plus les cambriolages et
agressions les vols à la tire et parfois
des crimes des choses beaucoup plus
graves à des sujets si vous voulez qui
se posent dans le sentiment d'impunité
ces sept c'est l'application des peines
en fait chaque fois que survient un
drame la réponse politico médiatique et
de demander une augmentation du quantum
des peines en fait le sujet n'est pas là
le sujet c est ce qu on peut enfin
appliquer le code pénal tel qu'il existe
les peines ne sont pas exécutés ou un
constamment ou tardivement
bref tout ça crée ce sentiment
d'impunité poursuivi les syndicats
policiers quand ils disent qu'il ya un
laxisme de la justice en réaction
justement à la mort de ceux de ce
policier
non moi je pense qu'ils voulaient que
les policiers font leur travail je pense
que les juges font leur travail
je pense qu'en revanche quand les peines
sont décidées par la justice jugée elles
ne sont pas ou peu exécuté je vais vous
donner un exemple les travaux d'intérêts
généraux pour l'aider des faits né cinq
ans qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
qualité de celui d'hier soir ne sont
exécutés je crois que 423 jours après la
commission des faits comment voulez vous
que tout ça est un
moindre élément d'exemplarité ça c'est
plus la question des moyens pour la pour
la justice puisque l'application
oui absolument il ya une question de
moyens dans la justice c'est à dire que
président de la république avait dit
qu'il construirait 15000 places de
prison dont 1 0 qui sortiront la fin du
mandat
il ya une surpopulation énorme dans les
prisons que fait on les greffes sont
encombrées que fait on bref la justice
est parent pauvre de la chaîne pénale
aujourd'hui puisqu'on parle de la
réponse judiciaire il ya un autre drame
cette fois qui s'est jouée à mérignac
c'est une femme qui est morte après que
son compagnon lui a tiré dessus et l'a
brûlée vive
elle avait porté plainte à plusieurs
reprises il avait été condamné il avait
fait de la prison pour des violences
contre elle
comment on en arrive encore aujourd'hui
à ce qu'une femme qui a porté plainte
qui est allé voir les forces de l'ordre
qui est allé voir la justice se retrouve
morte pour les villes mais tout est lié
sait que la chaîne pénale est totalement
encombré oui mais tant qu'ils osaient
les décisions ne peuvent pas être prises
à temps parce que que ça soit les
policiers que ce soit les juges n'ont
pas le temps donc pas les moyens
physiques et tout ça conduit à des gens
qui sont dans la rue alors qu'il devrait
être en prison qu'on libère plutôt
souvenez-vous dans la sphère du coc vide
on a dit on va diminuer on va on va
diminuer le risque d'une contamination à
l'intérieur des prisons qu'est ce qui
était fait ben ali belhaj en fait quand
vous regardez les peines
d'emprisonnement qui sont qui sont
fixées par les tribunaux désormais quand
vous êtes condamnés à moins d'un an mais
en réalité vous n'allez pas en prison
les peines ne sont pas exécutées en
france il n'y a pas suffisamment de
places de prison
je crois pas que ça soit une pierre à
jeter sur les juges ou sur les policiers
ou telle ou telle catégorie la question
n'est pas là c'est que les gens veulent
faire leur travail mais ils n'en n'ont
pas techniquement les moyens regardez la
paupérisation des services publics de
sécurité
regardez l'état des voitures des
policiers l'état de parcs informatiques
des policiers l'état des commissariats
en fait la police et la justice service
public
s'il en est souffrent de la même du même
état de paupérisation générale que tous
nos services publics
ce que j'ai vécu à l'hôpital et encore
moi j'ai la chance d'être dans un des
hôpitaux les plus
berne de france et quand je vois mes
collègues qui travaillent dans des
hôpitaux extrêmement paupérisée tout ça
est la même chose
la paupérisation des prisons la
paupérisation des tribunaux ceux des
commissariats ceux des hôpitaux
ce sont nos services publics qui parte à
vau l'eau parce que nous n'avons pas
nous ne sommes pas donné les moyens de
financer qu'aurélien ce montant sert
justement les moyens de la justice ou de
la ou de la police il ya quand même eu
des annonces je vous cite simplement le
l'augmentation de 8% du budget de la
justice annoncée par le garde la
regarder ça ça vous convient pas non moi
ce que je dis simplement c'est qu'il
faut qu'on arrête avec les annonces
c'est vrai que tout le monde fait des
annonces ont fait les années ça va être
appliquée on fait des annonces ont fait
des grands débats citoyens ont fait des
tables rondes mais sur le terrain
rockeur regarder quels et quels sont les
moyens qui ont été donnés à la justice
depuis quatre ans encore une fois ce
soit les les chiffres ne mentent pas il
ya un moment où il faut regarder les
données
le président avait dit durant mon
quinquennat j'ouvrirai 15000 places je
sais plus et 15 mai ou 17020 15000
places de prison y en a 10 15 milles
seront créés à 15,8 en cuir nappa qui
ont été créés y en a pas alors il ya eu
des rénovations ça il faut le dire
d'ailleurs souvent avec l'aide des
régions je vois en région ile-de-france
valérie pécresse a financé les régions
qui financent la rénovation des prisons
alors on le fait parce que c'est
nécessaire mais ce n'est pas nos
compétences eh bien il n'y a pas eu de
créations nettes
on ne doit y avoir 50 3000 places de
prison au royaume uni pour une
population même un peu moins grande
ils sont à 90 milles places vous voyez
le vrai sujet c'est qu'il manque un
tiers des moyens un tiers des places de
prison
et je ne vous dis pas l'état des
commissariats et la manière dans
laquelle les fonctionnaires de police
travaille en hollande il ya quelque
chose qu'il faut regarder qui est enfin
intéressant quand vous créez un poste de
policier vous êtes obligés de budgéter
évidemment son salaire et ses charges
mais aussi tout ce qui tourne autour
l'ordinateur la part de voiture le
bureau etc et donc du coup on assiste
pas cette paupérisation parce que quand
vous embaucher quelqu'un bien voulu
embaucher avec un environnement nous on
ne fait pas ça et donc on se retrouve
avec des services publics encore une
fois qu'ils sont qui tombe la france
tombe on va parler de la crise sanitaire
avec vous je veux dire à la sortie du
conseil des ministres gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement il a parlé
d'une amélioration nette de l'épidémie
est ce que c'est ce que vous constatez
vous dans votre hôpital
bon d'abord moi je les écoute plus parce
que chaque page et on en est toujours
dans des camps vous les écoutez depuis
un an
ça va toujours mieux on est les
meilleurs extraits quelle est la réalité
la réalité c'est que en nombre de cas on
a une diminution du nombre de cas en
france très clairement depuis une
dizaine de jours la courbe des minutes
le deuxième point qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est fondamental et c'est un des
éléments qui nous inquiète mois à
l'hôpital c'est qu'en fait ça ne
décroche pas ou très peu ou très
lentement plus exactement dans le nombre
de patients qui sont hospitalisés qui
sont qui occupent l'hôpital les lits de
réanimation sont encore très plein
j'avais le chiffres d'hier ou
d'avant-hier donc je suis peut-être en
retard parce que ça diminue mais on doit
être aux alentours de 5300 5400 patients
montréal mation 5400 entend des
mouvements bien quand on a confiné il ya
un mois et demi deux mois on était à
4200 donc on en avait moins aujourd'hui
la situation dans les hôpitaux n'est pas
meilleure elle est même pire que le jour
nous avons confiné notre inquiétude
c'est que les hôpitaux sont très pleins
et que ça va mettre beaucoup de temps à
diminuer chiffres quoi parce que les
patients restent plus longtemps des
précédents dingue oui oui probablement
il reste la seconde que je ne gagne
peut-être carnet en effet il ya quelque
chose qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que
quand vous prenez le nombre de morts par
semaine en france
on a passé la barre des 2000 morts par
semaine pendant cinq semaines seulement
il ya un an
enfin fin mars début avril l'élu apic
plus de mille morts par semaine pendant
cinq semaines cinq et là les deux mille
morts par semaine
on les a quasiment constamment depuis le
5 décembre
oui depuis décembre janvier février mars
à metz 250 à 300 morts par jour dont on
parle équivalent d'un
nana neuvième jour dans l'indifférence
quasi générale
donc non mais je suis ici parce que en
fait quand on se quand on accepte qu'il
ya 2000 morts
non pas par semaine non pas pendant cinq
semaines mais durant au quasiment 4 5
mois on accrédite l'idée qu'au fond ça
va pas mal ce que le message officiel en
permanence c'est à dire ça va mieux
en réalité ça ne va pas parce que nos
hôpitaux sont pleins et la conséquence
c'est quoi c'est que vous vous si demain
vous devez vous faire opérer pour une
pathologie qui n'a strictement rien à
voir avec le cockpit qui nécessite que
vous alliez au bloc opératoire ou en
réanimation pendant quelques jours et
vous ne pouvez pas aujourd'hui vous
faire opérer correctement parce que nous
n'avons pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
soigner tout le monde parce que nous
sommes les hôpitaux sont pleins en fait
la saturation elle est présente nous
sommes saturés alors monsieur ça me
permet de rebondir parce que vous avez
critiqué en effet le calendrier des
confinement en disant trop vite et sans
méthode sans méthode sur touré il en
méthode mais vous quittez taylor ait été
votre décision ces circonstances mais
d'abord je pense que j'aurais tout fait
sauf j'aurai tout décider sauf décider
tout seul dans mon coin parce que l'idée
de dire je décide moi même que on va
mettre un facteur de quatre cents 400
cas par an à travers 200 milles et qui
sera notre critère d'abord c'est un
critère qui est une propose sur pas
grand chose qui est très peu exigeant en
fait 400 en fait on l'atteindra jamais
heureusement d'ailleurs parce que ça
serait très très grave ça serait 38000
cas tous les jours et donc ça signifie
qu'on se met dans une situation de
descons fine et quoi qu'il arrive vous
connaissez le quoi qu'il en coûte mais
là on a le déconfinement quoi qu'il
arrive
en fait ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
veulent c'est ne pas être les derniers à
des confiné on voit les restaurants qui
rouvre en italie en allemagne en
grande-bretagne bien entendu et il se
dit zut
en france on va être les derniers donc
on y va c'est pas les bienvenus donc
c'est quoi ces politiques avec un risque
sur le plan sanitaire pour vauban
oui non mais bien sûr il y arrive sur le
plan sanitaire je vous le dis
aujourd'hui les hôpitaux sont très plein
c'est à dire que nous ne pouvons pas
aujourd'hui prendre en charge au plan
sanitaire la population dans les
conditions habituelles d'un pays
une grande puissance on ne peut pas
opérer le 19 mai c'est risqué pour ces
manifestants dont on n'a pas les moyens
il ya un deuxième élément c'est que si
on ouvre le 19 mai il faut se dit aussi
se donner les moyens d'ouvrir d'une
manière la plus sécurisée possible en
particulier où sont les bataillons de
gens qui vont nous aider à dépister
tracé isolé tout ça on est pas prêt où
sont les fermetures de frontières
j'avais je dois de gens pour détecter
les traces et vous ne pouvez les avoir
comme par exemple en allemagne que si
vous avez un nombre de contaminations
qui est relativement peu élevé il est le
hub à 6 mg kg en est à moins de 5000
contamination par jour est ce que par
exemple vous estime l'icg
il ne fallait pas des confiné avant de
revenir à un taux un nombre de
contaminations de viteos à munich et
2002 ça me plaît je repars bien sûr
c'est ça qu'il fallait faire d'ailleurs
en disant ça je suis un avenir venez pas
avant quelques mois en disant on l'a
souillé en disant ça je suis en accord
avec le président de la république qui
au mois d'octobre nous disait nous
faisait la leçon avec raison en disant
on ed confinera pas il parlait de début
décembre
si on a moins si on a plus de 5000 cas
par jour là on doit être à mettre à 25
22 25 mille cas par jour
donc ça signifie qu'on a on a cinq fois
si je vous suis monsieur julien pour
vous il ne fallait pas des consignes et
non mais c'est une question c'est très
dur d'être devant mais on en a tous ça
c'est du confinement on est tous
contents de sortir ce que je vous dis
c'est qu'au plan sanitaire
on ne se donne pas les moyens de de
confiner dans de bonnes conditions pas
d'isoler tracé pas de contrôle des
frontières pour empêcher que les
variants arrive parce qu'il ya quand
même ce sujet là on ne sait quand ce pas
suffisamment c'est le séquençage c'est
un examen qui vous permet quand je vous
fais le truc au fond d'une et je vous
dit vous êtes positif de d'identifier le
type de variants il faut faire ce qu'on
appelle du séquençage et ça ça vous
inquiète juste aujourd'hui c'est varié
en ile-de-france le médecin que vous
êtes se disent et c'est plutôt
inquiétant mais le seco a d'abord
aujourd'hui on a un variant qui est
avariée britannique très majoritaire
depuis un an me demande souvent est voué
à cayenne en fait je suis pas inquiet je
pense qu'il faut pas être ok il faut
être
il faut être très occupé il faut être
attentif et on est prêt ça c'est pas mal
non les variantes sont nés
on est sur l'ipad en réalité on dit ça
va parce qu'on ne savait pas c'est comme
les somnambules qui avance à regarder
autour d'eux je vous donne le chiffre
parce qu'il est très révélateur la
grande bretagne quand elle fait centre
éléments au fond du nez des gens en
disant c'est positif
en gros il ya 25% de ces prélèvements
qui sont séquencé et ils peuvent vous
dire quel est le type de variants nous
c'est 0,4 pour cent quand on prélève
sens on à 0,4 qui sont ces camps c'est
en fait on est un des pays qui
conséquences sont le moins et donc du
coup nous savons pas réellement quelle
est la circulation des variants sur le
territoire les chiffres auxquels étaient
pourtant ces îles notamment sur dario
brésil selvaria brésilien je leur mets
sur 0,4 pour cent des tests sur 0 4% et
ce qu'ils font ce qu'on fait ce sont des
dd c'est pas du séquençage et du
criblage quelque chose de beaucoup
apprécié pour entrer dans le détail sans
embêter les gens c'est que ça nous
permet pas par exemple de différentiel
sud africain du brésilien et vous verrez
que dans les statistiques officielles il
vous donne un chiffre en disant sud
africain ou brésiliens ah oui sauf que
ces études et ryu ses brésiliens et bien
comme on fait pas de séquençage
malheureuses secondes c'est pas répondre
à la question
petite question sur le passé ni terre
messieurs les députés vont débattre à
partir de la semaine prochaine sur son
utilisation
la description qu'on a fait le
le président avec une utilisation
surtout pour les grands événements mais
en sortant de son périmètre tous les
actes du quotidien du genre si je veux
aller au restaurant par exemple est-ce
que ça ça vous ça vous convainc est ce
que vous pensiez l'utiliser d'une autre
manière d'abord je pense que j'ai été
très réservée sur le passé car il ya
quelques mois parce que les gens
n'étaient pas vaccinés n'avait pas la
possibilité de l'être donc désormais ils
peuvent l'être ne pas sanitaire c'est g
impasse si je suis vacciné ou si j'ai
des anticorps parce que j'ai été
infectés récemment ou si j'ai un test
récemment négatif moi je me souviens sur
la rémission c'est encore la tension il
sait pas encore acté ouais mais c'est
vrai on sait par qui qui actent doré
dans ce pays est pour lui ces derniers
temps mais d'étudier nos cieux barre
aura lieu la semaine prochaine à
l'assemblée
à la hausse également pour une
utilisation à partir du 9 juin alléluia
donc il ya un débat qui va avoir lieu en
fin non mais c'est bien parce que je
suis intéressé dans une démocratie
parlementaire que le certains des
amendements à la loi que la sortie de
l'assemblée nationale enfin on va
pouvoir de contrôle c'était assez
extraordinaire non mais je veux dire par
là qu'il faut qu'il y ait un débat sur
ces sujets qui sont des sujets complexes
personne n'a la vérité il faut qu on
s'échange des arguments moi ce que je
crois et ce n'est que ma vérité c'est
qu'il faut ouvrir ce qui serait bien
c'est d'ouvrir l'économie évidemment
comment j'aimerais bien aller à une
terrasse d'un café part d'un café vite
et donc dans ces cas là dans ces cas là
le pass and i ter sur mon jeu sur mon
téléphone
c'est quelque chose que j'attends avec
une certaine impatience pour ça il ya
des conditions pour ça il faut qu'ils
soient fiables par l'eau il faut qu'il
soit interconnecté avec ceux de nos
voisins parce que nous sommes le premier
pays du monde de tourisme à toxines ou
voulons que notre industrie touristique
fonctionne il faut que l'allemand ou le
suédois qui viennent en france eh bien
ils sont son truc à lui puisse
fonctionner chez nous sinon je n'en vois
pas l'intérêt
enfin la question vous me posiez est-ce
que c'est seulement pour aller à un
concert de dix mille personnes ou pour
aller boire un verre au café il sait les
rassemblements très grands esserts camp
d'entraînement ou un café à la terrasse
en face moi je regarde ce que font les
autres hein je pense qu'on est tellement
en retard qu'en france on a au moins un
avantage sur avec notre tasse et qu'on
peut regarder ce que les autres font on
y serait ben oui c'est avoir longtemps
et en israël
quand vous allez au restaurant vous avez
impasse si ça peut accélérer et la
reprise de certaines activités
économiques bon moi je vois pas pourquoi
on s'en priverait
un dernier mot sur cette crise n tard on
parlait de l'actualité de votre parti
puisque vous parlez des consultations
parlement emmanuel macron il consulte
aussi beaucoup les maires en ce moment
dans son usage et à la presse que la pas
moi je suis il a promis d'associer les
maires il a parlé d'une grande tournée
en juin dans son interview à la presse
quotidienne régionale avec des principes
et julien est ce que vous le maire que
vous êtes sur écoute visiblement non ou
est ce que vous dites ce ne sont que des
paroles c'est que de la com ça c'est de
la com enfin écoutez je connais je suis
mère dans les hauts-de-seine qui est un
département important et qui est un
département où il ya une grande
concentration de population ont fait son
entrée dans département danse et à la
défense donc avec le centre d'affaires
européen et ses stars jeu je suis dans
les mers des hauts-de-seine
le maire je suis le président des
républicains qui est le parti politique
qui n'est pas non plus aussi négligeable
que ça en france moi j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu donner mon avis ah non on
m'a jamais demandé
enfin j'avoue fonctionner à
l'association des maires de france non
mais but vous avez
raison mais ce que je veux dire par là
on n'a jamais consulté un site encore en
tant que médecin au début de la crise
j'ai eu des échanges épistolaires avec
le président via une application il le
fait beaucoup avec les gens me dit oh
mais c'est vrai que en tant que père
dont je n'ai jamais en fait nous les
maires il ya eu vous savez cette affaire
on va on le président rémy nice avait
dit à une époque on va créer le couple
maires préfets et comme si c'était un
scoop enfin le maire préfet ça existe
depuis longtemps mais en fait le couple
maires préfets c'est quoi le premier
ministe faire décrire une déclaration
générale le jeudi soir il en voilà ce
qui va vous arriver et donc on la trouve
la prend par par la télévision et par
vous et puis le lendemain le préfet nous
convoque au téléphone et nous disent
qu'on a entendu la veille donc le couple
maires préfets c'est un couple un peu
asymétrie il existe depuis longtemps
mais il faut peut-être le le réinventer
ils sont minutes pour parler de votre
parti et l'actualité est chargée julien
oui on va pas reparler des donc des
républicains et puis d'une affaire
renaud muselier puisqu'il faut presque
l'appeler comme ça marche on avec sa
candidature aux régionales dans la
région paca avec l'aide dans quelle
mesure de l'hérault m est-ce que vous
pensez que la sphère muselier comme on
doit l'appeler a été mal gérée par les
républicains non moi je trouve qu'elle a
plutôt été bien gérée parce que c'est
quoi d'abord la sphère muselier parce
que les gens c'est la sphère muselier
c'est qu'on a appris par le journal du
dimanche
dimanche temps j'en vois il me
paraissait le samedi elle n'est pas
cadrée que jean castex nous annonce qu'
on ne sait pas titrait qui revendiquera
il n'y aura pas de liste en marche
en région paca une alliance avec elle
s'allie avec les républicains nous
n'étions pas au courant donc nous étions
contents d'apprendre ça montre que ça va
être en marche n'a pas été capable n'est
pas capable dans beaucoup de régions de
monter des listes qui sont des listes
significativement qui portent
significative au parce que en marche à
un problème de d'élus locaux il n'ya pas
de parti en marche sur le terrain
et deuxièmement ils ont voulu accréditer
l'idée que en fait en marche et les
républicains c'était pareil et donc que
du coup il y avait en marche et marine
le pen
nous nous sommes défendus en disant que
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec la
politique nationale qui venait pas à mes
yeux la crau ne sommes pas d'accord
c'est la démocratie c'est pas drame
nous ne sommes pas d'accord nous
pensions qu'elle est mauvaise pour la
france et à partir de ce moment là nous
ne faisons pas alliance avec eux donc il
ya une tentative d'opa inamicale de la
part de jean castex sur les républicains
qui a échoué
il essayait de faire un coup bas ça n'a
pas marché on on ne prend pas en otage
comme ça les électeurs en leur disant
bah écoutez moi premier ministre j'ai
décidé que vous n'auriez plus le choix
messieurs les électeurs vous n'aurez que
le rassemblement national ou que la
république en marche rien au milieu mais
non c'est pas comme ça ceux d'asie les
dernières questions julien oui mais c
est ce que vous craignez pas quand même
une forme d'explosion on voit que le
maire de toulon par exemple a déjà
signifié son départ quand on parle
également de christian estrosi est ce
que malgré tout cette tentative de
déstabilisation comme vous l'appelez pas
en train de fonctionner non je ne crois
pas au contraire on nous l'avons non
mais sérieux falco est partie bon c'est
quelqu'un de quelqu'un ya quelqu'un
christian estrosi va il était de l'isch
dans sa réelle dans son département en
tant que je doute qu'il parte
ce que je veux vous dire simplement
c'est que il ya des il ya des partis
politiques qui sont bien représentés sur
le au plan local nous en sommes si la
république en marche veut se présenter
aux élections régionales qu'ils y
aillent
chiche allez-y madame cluzel vous êtes
candidate chiche
faites votre liste et puis on ce contrat
après on a vu aux élections municipales
en marche ces deux pour cent des mairies
de france 2 pour cent donc moi je veux
bien qu'ils nous expliquent qu'ils sont
présents qu'ils auraient 2%
c'est calme c'est 5% je crois des voix
aux municipales
c'est une absence totale donc la
stratégie du coucou qui consiste à dire
je suis pas capable de faire ma liste
donc je veux mettre sur une liste et non
content de me mettre sur une autre liste
un autre républicain en plus
je la trust en disant que c'est plus
alizés républicain s'est mise en marche
maintenant ça ne marche pas en fait je
pense que tout ça détruit la politique
cette idée qu'on peut faire dès
combinazione c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement délétère
moi je suis très inquiet qu'est la
politique désormais de la majorité
présidentielle se soit une politique de
petits coups comme sa médiocre
médiatique des petits coups l'appareil
dont la politique ça se passe dans
l'urne donc ça se passe dans l'urne
rendez-vous dans l'urne
et merci beaucoup merci moi c'est ça le
message de la fin merci fils du vent
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin
[Musique]